Nos piden evaluar la expresión "a" cuadrada
más "10b" menos 8
cuando "a" es igual a 7 y "b" es igual a -4.
Así que para evaluar la expresión tenemos que sustituir en "a" el valor de 7 y en "b" el valor de -4.
Pues nos están pidiendo que evaluemos la expresión cuando "a" es igual a 7 y "b" es igual a -4.
Hagamos eso, cada que veamos una "a" en la expresión la sustituiremos por un 7,
tenemos entonces, "a" cuadrada,
que sería 7 al cuadrado, más...
más 10, lo voy a poner en el mismo color...
10 por "b", en vez de "b" tenemos que sustituir
el valor de -4, entonces más 10 por -4,
he sustituido esta "b" de aquí y todo eso -8.
Y ahora, vamos a calcular cuanto nos da esto.
7 al cuadrado es 49, luego a eso le tenemos
que sumar 10 por -4,
recuerda el orden de las operaciones, el producto va antes de la suma, entonces 10 menos 4 es -40
y nos queda esto,  49 más menos 40 y a todo eso le restamos -8, este -8 que tenemos aquí.
Así que ahora tenemos, 49 más menos 40,
que es en realidad 49 menos 40,
49 menos 40 es igual a 9 y si a 9 le restamos
8, esto nos va a dar igual a 1.
49 menos 40 es 9 menos 8 es igual a 1.
Y ya hemos terminado.
Hemos evaluado la expresión cuando "a" es
igual a 7 y "b" es igual a -4.